I will never sat down said oh here's how
you build a budget and have success with
money we ran up line up risking a lot
for our family been raising our family
Northwest Arkansas for many many years
we never SAT back and budget as a family
we didn't grow up budgeting we've made
so many poor choices of money went to
launch another company but with that
launch I really put our own personal
finances into launching that company
everything I thought was going to go a
certain direction over three year period
of time did not go he was spending a lot
of money in his business and he wasn't
communicating that with me it was all
since it was off her business it was
okay I wasn't a part of any of that I
was just a part of the effect of it all
guys sometimes don't have a risk meter
but women have a security gland and if
that thing ever spasms you know it can
go poorly August eleventh two thousand
eleven I'll never forget the day and
that's when Claudia basically pulled me
aside and she has told me she said you
can go now I'll take care of the kids
and that was for me was the wake-up call
then as a husband forever reason I
needed to be shocked into something
there's something that I had to look
inside and say what is it about me that
I've got a fix and in at that point I
actually have physically stepped away
from our bed at night i would take a cot
i had for the next 30 days i slept there
in the bathroom master bathroom she
needed her space for me and then she
needed me to go and show me quit quit
talking about it do you want to fight
for this or not and that's that's right
to prove do i want to fight that's when
i actually took the class of financial
peace university that's where I learned
the second week
about the security my wife
and how much she needs that security
then I look back I think about but he's
not handled God's money the way we show
we've earned a ton but we didn't always
make great decisions it was definitely
an eye-opener to see the change in him
after he went through financial peace
university and he told me you know at
the very beginning in three years we'll
have this all paid off and that just
seemed so far down the road because the
dead was so big and I began to see the
light at the end of the tunnel and I was
very proud of them and I respect him
very much for doing that because it
could have filed bankruptcy he could
have done lots of things but he didn't
and that says a lot about him and about
his character now that we know what God
wants us to do with our money we
literally sitting here debt free today
Scott and Claudia Fayetteville Arkansas
baby 159 thousand dollars paid off in
three years count it down let's hear a
debt free screen for family for friends
Arkansas FP coordinators our class
members three two one
big silly